one of the all-time greats and
congratulations to him on having the
winner's grandstand in Atlanta Motor
Speedway where NASCAR raced over the
weekend now name the Johnson grandstand
after him Jimmie Johnson here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you Jimmy I'm
doing great I love that dialogue earlier
about big bag of leaves and - yes we're
those during the commercial break of the
NBCSN audience we'll bring it right here
you did a Sports Center commercial with
Steve Levy my nickname in many big
nickname for him his big bag of leaves
right you did a sports center and where
you you took a part a speed bump in the
in the Bristol parking lot my car play
on where are you calling in right now
from Jimmy where are you right now I
yeah I'm in my car driving to the
racetrack there's some road construction
right to my tires I just roll out on my
cars oh no it's okay this is grimy knob
so I'm talking to a NASCAR legend
driving to race in a NASCAR race that's
actually what's happening right now
I know you're humble man I can call you
a NASCAR legend I mean you're seven-time
Cup Series champion what are you
thinking about other than calling into
the Rich Eisen show which I'm greatly
appreciative what do you think about
going to a track for a race what goes
through your mind Jimmy yeah the way it
works it works the way we run racing now
is way different what I've been
accustomed to have many more
responsibilities of my gear that's
required in the cars literally washing
my fire suits and a fireproof underwear
that go with it
have a cool shirt system that I could
look after in maintenance my helmet may
be female the radio system that goes
with it
hydration system that goes to the car to
everything that I come in contact with
with compartmentalizing things this day
as safe as possible
I'm now inherited all of those
responsibilities so literally I was
stressed earlier making sure I had all
my stuff packed up and right that I
wouldn't show up to the track and not
have something that I needed but
I'm driving up you know without practice
or qualifying there really isn't a lot
to be worried about cars going to roll
in off the transporter they unloaded it
goes through tech it's on the grid and I
get in the first lap we make it is our
parade box so there's really not a lot
to think about right now and what is it
like been racing during the pandemic
Jimmy is it once you're out there you
forget about there's no fans you forget
about the fact that when you do have to
[Music]
you know do anything that there's a
health protocol involved in it you have
the fan piece without a doubt three rays
and post-race commute again yeah there's
so many parts of my experience now
working without a doubt
notice the fans are there in these huge
venues with only the essential personnel
and actually racing and not doing like a
practice session or a test the best
really bizarre but when you're in the
car and at work John
eyeline is so focused on competition
you're caught up in battling the
competitors the car itself cantle decide
that I'm thankful that I'm not in a
sport where you really feed off me and I
hear you can hear the fans that feed off
of that that would take a huge
adjustment to so in in the racing
headspace it is business as usual but as
soon as you come out of that you're low
this waiter so you know we were just
talking with our previous guest Rick
Carlisle about the last dance this is
your I guess last ride right not tonight
specifically but this last season is
there any thought in your mind Jimmy I
must
I'm telling any tales out of school when
it comes to this thought process for you
and he thought in your mind saying you
know what this last season being so
unique it's in the middle of a pandemic
I want to maybe hope that the next
NASCAR season isn't in the midst of the
pandemic that what we are living life
like in kovat nineteen world is removed
and you could just have one last if you
will normal season anything like that
going through your mind Jimmy
you know in the pandemic started that
question was asked easier than even even
in my own head jail and chat door with
my wife but as you know I went through
the quarantine lockdown experience I had
a real look at what life might be like
not racing every weekend and it really
only cemented my feelings make this my
last first times more fun turn NASCAR
and would also helps me stick to that is
I have a bucket list of races bucket
list of cars that I still want to
experience so what's really I'm going to
sport where I can and I've had enough
success like actually hopefully kind of
call my shot
hey here's here's the top four or five
races I've always wanted to experience
but haven't had the time to because I'm
38 weeks here in NASCAR so I'm looking
at that list now trying to excel of it
go walk down and shut down anatomic you
know is used to follow I not sure what
21 will look like but that was my plan
pre-pandemic was let me go race these
different cars and all these different
tracks these different series and really
really have fun and bring it down to a
10 to 15 range as well instead of 38 so
can you walk me through that list right
now Jimmie Johnson yeah so for me I
think it's kind of a big bag of being
honest with myself about sponsors but
it'll go away quickly in that would
beginning are I've always wanted to
raise drive a GT car I'm not interested
in their oval so then if I might have
worked out but to experience one of
their cars on a road course or a variety
of road courses would be really amazing
to me I have attained struggled for the
one car a couple of years ago and that
just lit the fuse for him like wow you
know just this amazing I want anything
more that I've always had a big interest
in during sports car racing and there's
a longer runway for that kind of racing
for me yeah car key event there would be
to 24 hours of long there's another
event here in the States called the
Rolex 24 so that is sports car race not
like really hard ass
well I mean so you're saying you're
talking you know you're talking bucket
list in the Brickyard on Memorial Day
weekend is not on your bucket list Jimmy
Johnson if you could you know as a young
man without a family the Indy 500 was
absolutely top of my list I had a window
of opportunity to pursue it mr. Hendrick
do I Drive for NASCAR is going to allow
it
my wife and I had to agreement fire two
kids I could go race something like that
and then just having kids you know I
really feel like that opportunity's
mask' up those are some great men and
women that sit in those cars and where I
am in life I'm 250 miles an hour and
open cockpit
vehicle just doesn't know I guess out of
nervousness for you but also I hear what
you the way you put it was so
matter-of-fact it and it is so obvious
how old are your kids Jimmy and so
you're cooped up with them and you say I
want to stay here like like my god I
think you're like you're running off to
the racetrack to them my lord
wow I'm cooped up with a nine and six
year old we can't go outside nothing to
do I want to stay here that's impressive
Jimmy that may be more impressive than
your entire and ask our career I'll be
very honest with you well done so what
do you want to achieve in the next few
weeks here what do you what is your goal
here as you as you finish out this full
season string here yeah I think the
first goal is to get back to Victory
Lane
we've been off a bit of a dry spell here
you know and I'm glycol and it's very
possible for us this year so I'm looking
forward to that day and then if we are
able to win multiple events I really
feel like we become achieving the true
taking ship contender and threat so
there would be no better way to finish
up my final full-on year in NASCAR and
going out on top and kind of going out
as Manny did so I would love to create
that opportunity with my team
well if you do it's like Peyton Manning
did then you got to give a shout-out to
a beer sponsor
well you're lifting up the trophy I mean
if we can do it really like put Peyton
Manning did years ago but that I can
give you that you know I'm sure Peyton
keys sure I know I'm talking to a NASCAR
driver also you know what what about the
concept of inclusion I know you've had a
conversation with Bubba Wallace the only
african-american driver on the NASCAR
circuit right now he's gonna be driving
in a black lives matter vehicle this
evening what conversations have you had
with Bubba that you that you can share
with the audience right now Jimmy is a
great friend of mine and I'm really
proud of how gracious he's been through
all of this and his voice his friendship
relationships in the garage area has
really honored a ton of supports really
has helped educate a lot of us within
our industry on a corporate level and
unity that come from all of that is very
impressive and it's so fast talking to
me oh good do you remember him Myra's
ability to bring unity to our sport to
help create a common voice it is so
needed and so impressive so I'm really
proud of bubble so you and he have had a
conversation and I guess I wonder what
what you think you would what would you
say to fans of NASCAR who would who
might say you know what leave this off
the car leave this off the racetrack
leave leave this out of my viewing of
this sport certainly if I can't go
certainly you know
Bubba's mentioning that the Confederate
flag should be banned from any of these
events what would you say to any of the
fans who would be saying that Jimmy you
have such an influential voice when it
comes to the NASCAR fan clearly based on
who you are and what you have
accomplished
yeah I mean which which part there were
a couple really big topics there was
only us
I guess which what would you say to
fancy leave this stuff out you know that
I everybody has their own feelings and
beliefs and I personally disagree with
that and I think that we need to be more
vocal we need to soften people's minds
and help them you know and help motivate
people to have a deeper learning to
understand the in justices and the
inequalities that are out there so and
everybody is entitled to an opinion and
a right and I have an opinion and a
right to to have this answer I do and
that stance on the Confederate flag what
would that be Jimmy I'd support and that
support NASCAR that the Confederate flag
should not not be up in our sights
theatres racetracks in and you know in
our sport Jimmy Johnson you are a unique
individual when it comes to who you are
and what you what you mean to the sport
what do you say to fans who say don't go
what do you say to that right absolutely
they're right you know I for myself
personally in in dealing with you know
these troubling times obviously we've
gone through a pandemic where we're all
trying to learn as a society how to
fight this this virus
everybody is in a very heightened state
as a result and then you know we have
the just tragic death of George Floyd
and others that did a lot of racial the
racial injustice is - up to a peak and
it has been motivating for me to listen
and learn and I'm very happy with the
journey I've been on and I know means
preaching to others but if if others
could find a way to listen and learn and
to see where their hearts take them I
think that they would have a much
broader view of the picture at hand and
in what world is dealing with what the
black community is dealing with the
other man Jimmie Johnson
one for you have you ever met the
football Jimmie Johnson has there ever
been a Jimmie Johnson sonnet together I
have I have been around in multiple
times in my entire life I have always
had my name self of a wife
the last time I saw him he gave me a
hard time and said you know how many
people are spelling my name was ie now
because you I finally feel like I got
him back a little there you go
equal equal spelling errors I guess
right there I know you know so
hey Jimmy good luck tonight hope you see
that checkered flag if not tonight then
sometime down the line here and let's
reconnect really appreciate the time you
got appreciate it you got it that's
Jimmy Johnson ie very rare to talk to a
racer a driver on on race day right he's
heading to the track having himself to
the track right now with a I guess clean
fire underwear I did think hey I mean
you got to make sure you got everything
before you like cuz and people aren't
bringing it right people aren't bringing
it right now that's just like you've got
Declan your it got your own checklist
right there yeah hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here